[Music]
so time then for the press preview it's
our first look at what is on the front
pages of tomorrow's papers and this
evening we'll see what's making the
headlines with our two guests uh the
guardian columnist zoe williams and also
the telegraph's assistant comment editor
olivia utley a very good evening to both
of you good to see you we'll speak in a
moment we're going to check out those
front pages for you though first of all
starting with the metro leading on
number 10 struggle to defend claims the
prime minister did not know about the
conservative whip chris pincher's
alleged reputation for groping
pm facing cabinet backlash over pincher
is the headline in the telegraph
the daily mail says 22 000 crime
suspects failed to turn up to course in
their exclusive
on monday's front page the ft leading on
the european central bank which is
considering stopping banks selling cheap
lending schemes as it starts to raise
interest rates
the sun pictures the anyways essex star
who was involved in a car crash in
turkey which killed her boyfriend
and happy scorch of july says the daily
star as it predicts we could see
temperatures of up to 36 degrees wow 36
degrees
this coming week and don't forget by
scanning the qr code that you can see on
screen join the program you can check
out the front pages of tomorrow's papers
while you watch us discussing them and
i'm joined tonight by zoe williams and
olivia ali great to see you let's get
cracking olivia why don't we start with
you is it your paper the telegraph
front page pm facing cabinet backlash
over uh the ongoing story of mp chris
pincher i'm sure you saw working pension
secretary teresa coffey doing the
broadcast round this morning she was
certainly put through the ringer by our
very own uh sophie ridge um and uh
apparently some of them are complaining
yeah um that was a very awkward
interview and portraits coffee had other
terrible interviews um it seems so there
according to this telegraph story there
are three cabinet sources who are uh
there are rumblings that they're not
happy with being forced to come out and
defend boris johnson over the
appointment of chris pincher which he
was apparently repeatedly warned against
so we're now in the position where uh
there's a source being quoted in the
telegraph saying that over the course of
this week there are going to be cabinet
ministers with a surprising number of
dental appointments and and bereavements
um because they don't want to have to
come out and defend what what quite
understandably they see is indefensible
so it looks like what we're going to
have this week is is junior ministers
coming out onto the airwaves um and
being as you say put through the wringer
uh asked millions of questions about
about pincher which you know is going to
be very difficult for them it's going to
erode trust in in the prime minister
even further and it's going to just
generally be a very bad look so it just
feels again as though the prime minister
has got himself into another completely
avoidable crisis yeah you do often think
don't you that ministers hearts must
sink when they get that message saying
it's your turn it's your turn tomorrow
um
zoe um the prime minister heading into
another week then uh facing uh more
questions about his judgment
well the thing is i don't really agree
that it's another avoidable crisis i
mean that makes it sound like he could
have
a lot more strategically about the deal
with it
um and
something different but the truth is
you
completely turn a blind eye to
you know sexual harassment then it will
bite you and there's no way to get ahead
of that with media planning there's no
way to get ahead of that
with a kind of better grid
you know you have to have people in your
team who don't grope and harass people
who aren't
criminally prosecuted for
abuse you have to
we don't do these things and
unfortunately i have to say
i i agree with a lot of the commentary
over the weekend which is that the rot
starts from the top boris johnson's
never had personal standards and
his cabinet and his whimstone you know
yeah we're struggling a bit with your
sound we're going to try and we're going
to try and fix that uh zoe um olivia
just just finally then on this story
let's have a look at the front of the
metro actually while we are still
discussing it groping for answers uh is
there um a rather clever headline i
guess um how do you think that the prime
minister is going to play that um play
this in in the next couple of days
i just want to clarify quickly when i
when i said that um that he could have
played this a bit better and it was an
avoidable crisis i meant he shouldn't
have appointed a groper in the first
place rather than that he should have
had a better media officer up to to
defend the groping practices um i don't
know how boris johnson is going to deal
with it yet again it just feels as
though he's hoping that something good
is going to come up um he's the sort of
perennial optimist which in good times
has made him this charismatic
happy-go-lucky guy who
is very popular in the public but it's
also his worst flaw because he does sort
of walk into situations head in the sand
and just
when everything goes wrong puts his
thumbs up and goes oh well something's
going to come up and it doesn't come up
and there is this is completely
indefensible and there's no excuses
seems incredibly clear that he did know
exactly what was going on and he ignored
it so it is just
you know how do you get out of this i
don't know how can you possibly play it
there is no way of playing it okay all
right well let's uh move on to a
different topic front page of the
guardian zoe um why don't you tell us
about this one
so i always wonder why um the kind of
liberal press breaks things down in this
way you know they say
they say
lonely parents are struggling more than
any other parents children in lone
parent families are struggling more than
any other children
now it turns out that you know it's
one-fifth of all children are in lone
parent families and 60 of children in
lone parent families are living in
relative poverty which is not just
you know which is a really serious state
of affairs you're taking the kind of
median level of poverty and then you're
saying that they significantly below
that when you consider how much
everybody's struggling at the moment
that's a really significant deal the
thing which i kind of disagree with in a
way is that it's actually quite they you
know they call this kind of new and
exclusive research but it's actually
very very obvious as a kind of logical
inference that if people in two parent
working families are struggling if
people then people in one parent working
families are going to be struggling more
so
they're trying to make a case i think
that did this kind of cost of living
crisis and the general
overhang of austerity is hitting parents
in a kind of
you know sexually biased gender biased
way hitting women hardest hitting lone
parent families hardest but i
i i would lean towards saying
there needs to be a really concrete
effort for all families who are
struggling because it simply isn't the
case that um that this was a sort of
sexist policy that has thought this is
this about this is simply the result of
poor management over now
10 or 11 years
well what it does do it certainly um
sets up the scale of the crisis doesn't
it olivia when it comes to child poverty
yeah absolutely and uh as though he says
sort of between a quarter and a fifth of
all children are growing up in
single-parent families and um this
there are statistics on what was
happening in sort of 2014-15 but and it
just before the pandemic hit but
it seems very likely that the problem
has only got worse um ever since covid
hit obviously
as though he said it's sort of obvious
that a single parent is going to be hit
harder than a double income parent and
then we have the cost of living crisis
on top of that um so i think sort of
drawing attention to those children
living in those families it's quite it's
quite a useful thing to do and i think
actually the the pandemic and lockdown
obviously did hit single parents
particularly hard
because being stuck at home in a in a
small flat with your with your children
and no adult company to to sort of keep
you balanced must have been extremely
extremely difficult and we're seeing the
we're seeing the results of that all
over the place we're seeing results that
in terms of uh violence against children
being on the rise and definitely child
poverty is is just increasing um so you
know another wake-up call to to
sort out the cost of living in crisis in
some way that is more meaningful than
just sort of getting onto tv and hoping
that a minister can can dig you out of
another crisis um
government's too distracted to deal with
this problem yeah and um and just before
we go to the break zoe let's look at um
yet another crisis um another area of
life that uh
we're having to struggle with uh a
record four month wait apparently
according to the daily express to to buy
a house because of of the broken system
i mean it's really peculiar of the
express to make this
to make this case the way they do
because in typically in the media
landscape nobody has been more excited
by house prices going up than the
express that and so you know as you've
seen the market accelerate to a point
where normal working people on normal
salaries could never afford to buy a
house anymore the people with the kind
of caster nets doing the flamenco around
the courtyard were always the daily
express saying house prices experience
record 15 rise um
now obviously there is a
there is a kind of administrative crisis
in the same way that there's an
administrative crisis post it's them for
passports postcoded just in the sense
that you know there's a gigantic backlog
there's a gigantic market correction sin
following the um stamp duty suspension
and then reinstitution there's a
gigantic
you know surge of interest among a very
small number of people who can afford to
buy and exchange housing stock
and that's telling in the time it takes
to buy it
but
you know the express really needs to
have a word with itself from a year ago
or two years ago or five years ago they
were the cheerleaders for this
completely warped and disorganized
system in which that you know the number
of people actually exchanging housing
stock has cons got smaller and smaller
and smaller and then we've been the
benefits of that okay all right we'll
leave that there and uh we shall uh
speak again in a moment because coming
up we'll have more uh from the papers
including this story also on the front
of the guardian several killed in
denmark gun attack that horrific attack
in copenhagen discussing that more in a
couple months
[Music]
[Music]
now again part two of the press preview
olivia and zoe uh still with us uh front
page of the guardian uh olivia this
awful story um uh uh this evening um
hearing from the police uh several
people were shot dead uh at this
copenhagen
shopping center
a man has been arrested 22 year old
danish man but um just uh just awful
absolutely awful um
remember what happened in in reading
here a few years ago and these other
lone seemingly possibly terror attacks
um it devastates the whole country and
you know just thinking of the friends
and family who who have
lost people um
we know very few details yet there is
this 22 year old man in custody uh
people are injured three people are dead
three three possibly four um but yeah an
awful tragedy
yeah they know that several are dead and
several injured we haven't got the the
figures yet but i'm sure they'll come in
over the next few hours um your thoughts
on this zoe
i mean there is a
there is a kind of history not a huge
history but a very significant one in
scandinavia with kind of right-wing lone
wolf terror attacks
um and it's not obviously we don't know
yet whether that's what this is but but
there there are questions to answer for
the scandinavians because they do
basically have a lot of um
anti-immigrants stoking rhetoric even
within quite progressive politics and
that throws up these really peculiar
um very violent events which i think if
they didn't indulge themselves so much
in mainstream politics with that
language would be easier to track ahead
of time
okay um let's just talk briefly about
the situation in ukraine it's on the
front of the ft number of other papers
as well um
russia does seem to have the upper hand
doesn't it certainly certainly in in the
east of the of the country and we're
hearing that lizzy shanks
another key city has uh has fallen to
the russians olivia
yeah it is beginning to feel a bit like
that um i discovered today that the
battle of the donbass is one of the
longest battles ever it's just raged for
such a long time now and it feels a bit
as though some of um zelensky's
supporters in the west are you know we
saw that g7 we would all of the rhetoric
was there and it was all right but it
feels a little bit as though uh
the the momentum has gone a bit from the
from from the west side in supporting
ukraine um and they're making the right
noises but as we can see you know
schultz has promised so many weapons the
weapons haven't actually arrived
everything's been a bit slow and it is
feeling as though that sort of weariness
in the west is allowing russia to
seemingly get the upper hand um and if
the battle
that you know the hope is that putin's
men are going to time we've seen time at
time again military experts coming out
and saying that their army yes it's big
um but it wasn't properly trained
they're losing troops at an alarming
rate etc um so you know the hope is that
putin's men will tire but at the moment
that doesn't quite seem to be happening
um and the donbass does seem to be
well i'm not going to say falling to
rush because that's that's
too far but but it's not a good
situation and i think it's a it's a it's
another wake-up call to keep our eyes on
what's happening in ukraine because
you know
we weren't expecting war like this and
now we're here and
we can't just let zelenski suffer yeah
okay um we haven't got time to talk
about the front of the daily star i was
going to bring this in we'll perhaps
talk about it in the next hour happy
scorch of july 36 degrees swelter belter
ending the hour on a little bit of good
news the weather is set to to stay nice
the next few days